good morning everyone the morning
Millennials good morning how are we
doing we're doing good we're doing tired
but I'm doing better than Monday like
for sure I don't this is technically our
Thursday I know no it's amazing I woke
up this morning so sad and then I
remembered like okay it's a three-day
workweek like I can do that no I woke up
today like in a tizzy because I don't
know who I thought I was MA Theo a
haircut and like Beth appointment at
9:00 and I don't even leave my house
till like 9:30 so I don't they call me
at 9:15 they're like where's Theo I'm
like who is this so it was so frantic
but Ben didn't take fresh tags like the
groomer like I started to take him to a
place and they did wash cut toenails
teeth everything $200 yeah of course
$200 so now I only go like once every
two months but they also do like daycare
so I used to have someone come to my
house and she still does but like that I
have to rush home you know like yeah
they do daycare he gets to hang out with
the other dogs so it's like $200 for all
that plus daycare which still doesn't
make any sense but it's whatever he
deserves to treat himself every once in
a while yeah not like he's paying for no
totally he's literally like sometimes I
just think like I wish I was my dog they
have no problems like they don't to
worry about paying bills or like getting
brands to sponsor your podcast like they
don't worry about anything it's like he
gets in trouble but I don't think like
he has the emotional capacity to have a
pet I think that everyone I think he
gets past it will real quick I think
interesting knows he did something wrong
you want to hear an interesting
journaled with his weight a lot like
he's been through a lot
well no no maybe because he was body
shamed by you because he was fat do you
want
she went here an interesting statistic
since I got the O from his trainer and
when we were in Turks and Caicos
instigators know he's only had two
accidents and he goes to the bathroom
four times a day like that's pretty good
I know I'm really proud of him and one
of them I wasn't there and it was
totally Ben's fault and the other time
like I just didn't take him out so
obviously he had to pay I take
responsibility so Theo is blameless okay
you guys we're gonna get into it no I
just don't want to talk about other side
you want to talk about
no I have a pit I just have a pit okay
talk to you about my pants sure you know
I keep talking about it like you know
all of it people are loving my outfit
and I literally have never looked worse
like I look like a farmer you look bad I
could be a farmer in those clothes you
don't look bad you look different like a
different person
you know what who you look like Mattie
papi our third story okay I just I just
was feeling relaxed and I didn't want to
gene too tight and I just I didn't do
you girlfriends and then like a
Calabasas girl which is such a
compliment the biggest you cap it you
know what it's about cuz I've been
talked about a non-stop for the past
week is this apartment maybe look at the
advice of are the toasters because
they're really smart and we have some
real estate yeah okay so me and Ben are
moving and it is so damn expensive like
it's blows my mind and I'm always like
of the mind that I would rather live in
like a less cool area and have like a
much bigger apartment then like live in
like the cool downtown agree and live in
like a shoebox and pay more money like I
don't care where I live like I over
everywhere and I just want the best deal
for the most space you send a lot of
time at home that the home should be
yeah so me and Ben found this apartment
that is literally gorgeous it's it's
obviously not cheap but like for moved
New York real estate like it's $1,300
less than like I would pay for it like a
month like it's crazy
two bedrooms two bathrooms so there's a
shower and a bath like Ben never has to
be in my bathroom again second bedroom I
would totally make into like a YouTube
podcast like studio and then would you
because since she was saying something
about you making in a bedroom in her
sleep now I have like two making her oh
my god mind sets she was like cloudy
can't get this apartment oh but she was
like Ben I'm gonna sleep there oh she
sleeps in my house now all the time
either when Ben's not there or on the
couch and like but she would be living a
block away like doesn't matter so I'm
then now I'm like stuck in this
hypothetical like when I make the second
bedroom like a bedroom and like have
Margo sleep there and like some of Ben's
friends but then I like encourage people
to be in my house and I don't really
want that or like a glam room
YouTube like basically a second room for
me a home office yeah and you could also
put a Murphy got in there that's like so
futon and also like if you're sleeping
over like wouldn't you sleep in your bed
with you if
it's out there but Ben sometimes is
there okay wouldn't be able to sleep in
theater you guys are missing the point
what did she see I just like the Oh his
own bedroom oh my god he wouldn't even
appreciate he wouldn't understand
okay so sorry I'm getting off track so
we found this apartment we're still we
put the application in so we're still
not approved so I could be talking about
nothing because I could not get approved
but like I've amazing credit actually
what's good credit I don't know I think
I have like average credit but it's like
I haven't lived enough to have good it's
about to say your credit like is it a
secret no but like money instead of
saying your actual number like what the
letter did they gave you was oh I don't
see a letter oh they used to Credit
Karma I never had to do any of this
before like it's wild you can use you
can check your credit now like through
the chase app the way yeah cuz all your
business is like is it bad to say your
credit No I'm embarrassed bad
seventy-five yellow is okay I use yellow
to yellow is a see I see you that it's
fine you pass but I am great like I'm a
good person but like you haven't had
enough opportunity to bail credit like
right now while you have for credit is
your credit card which you pay on time
which is fine but like you've never had
a house or like your home yeah I'm bit
like so that sort of stuff builds credit
right now you've done the one thing to
build credit that you how much is a
credit card okay so you're decent
whatever I'm a nice girl so you should
write your apartments to me everyone's
writing their credit scores I'm glad is
it higher than mine everyone's is higher
than yours yeah but they said that
that's good credit okay whatever it
didn't say red so I was like it's fine
yeah you're fine
so this apartment sorry I'm getting off
track so it's virtually perfect except
for like it's on the worst block like in
America yeah well that's um that's
confusing because it makes it seem like
it's on the worst block like it's like
trash you know and it's not like it's
not criminal it's not like in a bad area
is just an ugly lock it's like
inconvenient it's right by it like an
entrance to like a bridge so like
there's like traffic like I just like
hate the block but is that like a deal
breaker for the perfect apartment the
perfect underpriced Department I don't
know right like you're paying that price
because I'm your block right but like
literally these bathrooms are marble
like all over like it's gorging so it's
like can I look past that I don't know I
think that you can I know so look at
that I let the chips fall where they may
yeah because
your application is in if you got it
meant to be if you don't not meant yeah
once you start thinking of things in
that way it's just like yeah and like if
she if they yeah it's meant to be it'll
be it'll be baby just let it be so won't
you ride with me ride with me see where
this thing goes if it's meant to be
it'll be it'll be
baby just meant to be okay so it's
attacks he'll be a problem you know if
they decline us I'm not gonna like put
in another offer like even though like I
would technically pay like what I offer
now I would pay like a little bit more
but a little bit but if we get to
client's like it's not it's not meant to
be now than 10 being apartment I end up
in I will be comparing to this one I
don't know everything happens for a
reason sis I never thought I would end
up in the apartment that I'm in now and
we never want to move like this was was
me a temporarily yeah cuz when we
started when Zach and I started looking
for apartments it was library and it was
just couldn't have comment like a worse
time like I just lost my job
just everything change and like we
didn't know where we needed to be where
we were gonna be doing the show huh so
we just like had to choose an apartment
we kind of like how did we were like
suppose you like this apartment will be
perfect for the year and then in a year
we'll know what's what and we go there
but we we're never gonna leave until
probably we have kids because we really
yeah and it's like the way the
apartments set up it's like when Zach's
in living room and I'm in the bedroom
like we can't hear each other right like
I can't hear his CV he can't hear mind
and even when am i calling out maybe he
can hear me yeah but it's like the way
it's set up it's like the map the best
use of space and I love it well now I'm
of the mindset like I [ __ ] hate my
apartment and like I can't wait to leave
because like I'm just seeing other
better apartments and I'm like off this
parent stuff but also like I feel like
when you first moved into your apartment
like maybe it was everything and you
were obsessed with it and as you've you
know lost your obsession with it like
it's rubbed off on top because I'm I'm
in less care of it and for me now I'm
like whether you think I don't eat my
apartment only really because there's
only one toilet and like I just can't
live like that like I need another
toilet and like I hate managin and your
keep your bathroom anger kitchen is not
renovated but see this is you never get
everything you want in an apartment so
when I got to this apartment I was like
okay the kitchen and the bathroom are
like a little dated but like I have
floor-to-ceiling windows like you never
get that so I'm like you know you always
pick and choose you don't get everything
so what's a prioritize so now I'm like
okay I have everything I want except for
the block is that high on the priority
list I don't think so no it's it's it's
a good deal it is yeah you should do it
I love a deal like I'd rather live in
like a lesser like a less fancy building
I don't know I'm just I'm so torn I
think I think you know what you have to
do and I heard a rumor that there's
someone I know that lives in the
building and then that makes me not want
to move because like I don't need to be
running into people when I'm like trying
to walk see you I don't know so many
people like live in the building I live
and I think I don't ever see anyone live
in a huge building this is like a
smaller building with two elevators
that's true and I'm I feel like so many
people in the building like no I'm
always running on the building like
looking like trash like just oh yeah
doing things and I just feel like people
recognize me and you'll see I'll be
really happy that it's bad for business
I will be happy to be getting out of
Murray Hill because like that's so our
demographic and while I do love it like
it's very high rates like walk Theo and
like know that people are taking
pictures of me and like I look like you
should see how I walk Theo like and I
know Shane I can imagine no shame so I'm
looking forward to being like more like
um in an area where I don't think anyone
gives a [ __ ] more anonymous yeah totally
well I think you know what you have to
do sister well let's see if I gotta
prove I know so just if you're ever like
feeling like confused or doubting
yourself
just remember it's meant to be it'll be
it'll beat but it's your favorite song
it really is but not that part I don't
even like the course I like I don't need
to be so uptight by a couple guys that
didn't treat me riding I ain't gonna lie
I'm just like in love with bebe Rexha
these days I'm happy for you that you
found solace let's jump in I'm excited I
feel like we've been doing like really
nice episodes we haven't done like a
regular episode with five random stories
in a while
Plus here toasters is it Wednesday do
you have the DJ why are we doing here oh
I think they're for tomorrow I've sent
them for Windows sorry I got ahead maybe
this tomorrow because my sister they
tear toasters is the day of the week
that we remember to do it you know yes
sir it's not really a weekly thing
anyways we're gonna hang you with the
best ice trays that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and you know just
so much happen that we we just must talk
about if it is crazy how we through the
show everyday like we never have nothing
to talk about like the world just
doesn't stop
I know but there are some of these where
the stories is pulling teeth but then
like you know we we make up for it with
our you know glowing personalities
tonight say something you know how like
popular podcasts they had their fan
bases they can't get on Facebook groups
that's like how it goes and we have one
and like do you know that we're the
we're the biggest one really because and
just by the research that I've done the
biggest one was lady gang
how many did 22 and we're at 23 what
about skinny confident I forgot to check
because when I don't like I'm not doing
that I joined for a little and they it
was huge yeah maybe she's bigger than us
we're up there I was so new there is
like a cap on how big these groups can
be because it starts to like get so
crazy I had we haven't reached it yet
but like it's so crazy but it also
depends on the type of environment that
you posture foster so like when there
are groups where it's like no holds bar
say what everyone about anyone like then
it gets insane people's like families
get involved in like people start like
showing up to like real housewives
houses run like babysitting their kids
but we have like rules where it's like
the point of the group is like to make
friends and like get along so like I
don't feel like the people infiltrating
our group are like wanting to go to
Heather Dubrow house and like a
kidnapper kid you know oh my god yeah
totally and like I think we're it me
doing a good job like that I'm saying
like you can say whatever you want for
the most part and we use our judgment if
it's gonna stay yeah you know so good
luck okay first story really everyone is
so interested on it like so are we but
I'm also I'm also skeptical me too
because news reports that ariana grande
is dating Pete Davidson quotas but an
actual but she's quote very happy
everyone report it not even doing okay
but no but this is the the source I'm so
I'm not just like pulling it out of my
ass okay these are the facts that enews
has ariana grande is seeing SNL comedian
Pete Davidson enews has learned it just
started and it's casual source says
coincidentally their budding
relationship comes soon after both
Ariana and Pete ended previous
relationships the no tears left to cry
songstress confirmed her split from
rapper Mac Miller earlier this month
likewise news broke just last week that
Davidson and Cassie David had broken up
after two years together the source
explains that despite Ariana and Mac
officially breaking up after coach Allen
April the relationship hadn't been over
long before and then it goes back into
Ariana and Mac and then he got a DUI
last weekend and so I always thought
that like aren't gonna grande could do
better than Mac Miller so like I'm happy
for her that she's moving on
and I never thought that about Pete
Davidson actually thought him in CAHSEE
David we're like perfect for each other
a grain and looked alike they had like
really similar vibes like I with them
once they were just like so perfect for
each other
so like while I'm sad that that ended I
want ariana grande to find happiness you
know mm-hmm and I kind of like that Pete
Davidson is like a girlfriend [ __ ] like
he doesn't like [ __ ] a bunch of girls he
just like has meaningful relationships
with a lot of girls like used to date
art Carly Aquilino until you see what
Carly Aquilino tweeted yeah she's like a
she's like a chip of Beyonce like
looking like shady yeah um he's so
confusing to me though because like he
tastes like such hot girls hm and I
wouldn't like qualified him as
occasionally as a grade a hottie no but
like Ariana Grande like doesn't like hot
dudes no Anna is not hot no Big Sean is
hot yeah let you date before that Nathan
like one of the teeny boppers oh right
oh and then she dated that guy and I
hate to bring it back to this because
she's come so far but with like the
donut video one of her backup - oh yeah
yeah but she's come she doesn't have
good taste in men but not all no she
does not a nice choice I like Pete
Davidson yeah me too I'm I just feel
like I don't believe that they're
actually dating I feel like maybe they
hooked up and then like everyone's
blowing out of proportion like you know
yeah I also am not a hundred percent
sure that he is fully done with Cassie
right she posted a picture of the two of
them three weeks ago he also has her
name tattooed on his ring finger like
his wedding ring he changed it he got
like three stripes
he pulled a Jack's maybe maybe this over
yeah I don't know I'm just I'm I won't
believe it till I see it like until
they're the picture of him stepping out
together
I'm skeptical about this just because
like when did they even mean it's just
like hard when you're literally like the
most powerful woman in the world like
Ariana Grande I think is one of like
probably the top five pop stars in the
world yeah like I would do like her
Taylor Swift Rihanna Rihanna like maybe
Selena or Demi look they're the top five
yeah and people will be like and then
above that is like Beyonce Lady Gaga
like legends but the end actually I'd
put Rihanna up there but they're like
the top five like right now yeah you
know and so I bet it's hard to just like
find a man cause like you're literally
like the most one of the most powerful
people the world say you were Ariana
Grande we've done this before every day
it's your
find someone for Ariana Grande if you
were in Ariana Grande's body wish upon a
star style yeah who would you date so
I'm powerful I'm in the music industry I
would probably want to date someone out
of my industry so that like there's no
competition
you're like awkwardness right like
people that we've worked with so maybe I
would dabble in like sports or sports
but like the traditional movie star yeah
they do and I don't like sports athletes
cheat and the travel and it's just
unsustainable but I feel like actors
like lie and they yeah because they're
actors and they're a bleep date honestly
like no I was about to make the worst
call like an influencer but then like
you literally yeah no that's bad call
does that go Zac Efron Oh Zac Efron or
Nick Jonas or Josh Groban not Josh
Groban but I see like the Disney vibe
you know she's a Nickelodeon star so
someone who blossomed a Jonas Brother I
feel like it's like a good guy but Kevin
Jonas he's married with children I know
I'm kidding
so what's wrong with Nick nothing I love
him
I don't okay um no it's just she is we
were tasting guys it's almost like she's
like insecure I know but like she's
literally March the most gorgeous total
like the type of the types of guys she
dates doesn't reflect who she is you
know maybe it might be like a projection
of what she thinks people see her eyes
for sure but like how do you not know
what you are like not only is Mac Miller
like really not that hot he's like not
famous either yeah memory she looked at
the doughnuts that was so weird you know
that Mac Miller song now like it's
freaking me out but I took a beat a pill
in Ibiza tennis not Mac Miller does Mike
Posner yeah they're the same I took a
bit look exactly like to show vici I was
cool can't listen to that when I got
sober okay anyways I hosted this is true
but until I see if he tripping together
I'm skeptical but I'm happy for her and
I'm happy for him they both seem like
like nice people
Yeah right any further thoughts I feel
like he's like really cool to know to me
and he's like a cool has to because he's
like just you know pulling all this tail
you know not not only that but like he's
like in SNL like everyone in the world
like really respects him as a comedian
know and also it's like when
he is on SNL like he's not on in a lot
and when he is like he literally barely
says anything like people die for him
like he says like dilly dilly I don't
know I just feel like everyone respects
the hell out of Pete Davidson similar to
the morning toast it's very very similar
it's nice being respected it is okay
this next story shakes me to the core
because because we called it we were
talking about this yesterday Camila
Cabello cancels her performance on
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift's tour due to
quote dehydration literally yesterday if
you watch a morning toast which
obviously the whole world and you should
if you didn't watch Esther's episode it
was the Royal recap and the BBM a recap
and it was really good and we were
talking about how there was clearly
something wrong with Camila Cabello
she's obviously physically mentally
emotionally something is off something
is off
she's like she's just being weird she
was on something at the B be amazed and
we just kind of said as a throwaway
comment because kind of like everyone's
on something and then it comes out that
she has canceled Tuesday's performance
on Taylor Swift's reputation tour citing
dehydration quote so yesterday after my
performance at the billboards I was
feeling really sick and ended up in the
hospital they got checked out Kibeho 21
tweeted late Monday quote they ran a lot
of tests and everything is fine but the
diagnosis was basically dehydration and
I also have a low-grade fever the
doctors have told me I really have to
get rest otherwise I won't get better so
unfortunately I won't be able to perform
my set during the reputation tour in
Seattle tomorrow okay let me cite some
other celebrities who have also been
hospitalized for dehydration and then as
your resident blind researcher I will
cite the blondes so some other
severities who have been hospitalized
for dehydration during their career
Lindsay Lohan I believe Mischa Barton I
believe Kelly Osbourne really I think
and I believe I'm Selena Gomez oh yes
term just but just you just something to
think about so here's what the brides
are saying
Taylor Swift is on tour with Charli XCX
and Camilla Kibeho
apparently Charli XCX that Camilla
kebaya both share a hobby of putting my
powder up their nose and it's gotten so
out of control and Taylor it's like
businesswomen special like that does not
fly in her tour like and apparently she
doesn't know about it and if she were to
find out she would be furious so her and
Charlie are just like this whole week
they've only been on tour for a week and
they've like non-stop partied and
obviously it's taken a toll on Camilla
because she had to fly to Vegas all that
so Charli XCX wasn't that cool so that's
just what the blinds are saying I wonder
if Taylor knows I don't know if we know
she knows but I feel like she wants to
help her friends and I feel like giving
them work is a way of helping them hmm
to like you know get on the street in
there I had heard that Camila was making
probably a little more than 50 grand for
each show that's great that's crazy like
for just being so early in your career
but it's such a big tour and what it's
probably like a hundred shows that's
what five million dollars I don't know
50 times 100 I don't know I mean I
realized recently that I'm like really
bad at math I think it's five million
yep fifty seven whatever anyways I told
it crazy cuz like we called it yeah and
it was just like it's so crazy because
and I was just so I felt so just effects
I was talking with Zach we're watching
the awards I was like she's like drunk
or something and he was like no and then
I say we're sittin on the couch again I
was like Camila Cabello has been
hospitalized I was like told you so
wait and this is so random but the song
that they use for the Bachelorette promo
woman by I didn't realize that it was
the same song that like I love you no no
they do these changes to independent
because it's [ __ ] and so that's
probably the radio version is much
better our [ __ ] for sure
anything ruin all day shouldn't change
independent to like a word that would it
actually be make sense for a woman who's
the bacterin
right think they're like a hardly
independent like I'll get codependent
I'm a romantic woman baby all right I'm
a desperate little woman baby I'm a
thirsty [ __ ] thing but I'm a woman
[Laughter]
it's just like no you're know your
audience
like I think of you literally goes on TV
to find love is hardly independent
you're anything but independent was
actually trying everything she's doing
everything in her power to to not be
independent to be dependent right I'm a
dependent well done babe except did you
ruin all songs but with Rachael Lindsey
they made that that's my girl because
she is my girl first of all second of
all like I don't really know that song
before and like that was just that was
so raychel like that's my girl
know and like and whenever I hear it
like Rachel Lindsey is still my girl
like you know I still think like I'm not
thinking of anyone else I'm thinking
look I think the racial is he has my
girl I do not think of Becca coupe as an
independent woman no and like when I
hear this young woman like I'm not
thinking of Becca no I took me I saw the
trailer and I'd listened to that song
100 times took me like literally a week
to realize that that song when that song
came out it was the weekend that I
rented the convertible and had the ride
of my life so it reminds me of of me and
the computer I wasn't an independent
woman because I had to be driven around
yeah Kim Zolciak style but then it was
[ __ ] so I didn't want to be
independent you know it was just being a
[ __ ] good with my lethal
seller scarf um anyway singing of Camila
Cabello hope you hopefully get better
and they sincere sounds like disappoint
your fans yes seriously it's a week one
of the tour like you can't hang no it's
week one of them this is our third city
and like a lot of people like it's not
like she's a nobody like people are
coming for her
people are doing us other versions on
the solution issue I'm a future podcast
woman Thank You Maddie Hatcher okay I'm
a fifty selling woman baby oh right
that's sugar bear hair I'm a sugar bear
hair selling woman babe I like future
podcast woman I'm a current podcast
woman I'm hopefully or above woman oh
right I don't know if I am cool enough
they picked the worst ones and I need to
get a new camera baby oh right did you
see was Rachel Lindsey's birthday she
had a sad sad day when - I'll tell you
went down she had a 99 mm themed
birthday party mm-hmm and she did an
Instagram story and she was like thank
you to everyone who came out and to some
of my friends like what did she say
she said my friends you know who you are
like you really like supported me yeah
and it's like the only friends of hers
that we know about were there
are the bachelor girls and they all live
in Dallas now like I know they all went
to Dallas for the party and then after
the rest of the weekend like they were
throwing down and like Rachel it wasn't
there so like it's like you have to just
you know infer that she's talking about
those girls like what could they have
done I don't know but it's like don't
pay I'm hungry I don't care don't piss
off big rage okay next up
Maddie poppy wins season 16 of American
Idol so man is dating runner-up Caleb
Lee Hutchinson okay so you want to
explain okay so last night was the
finale of American Idol and the top
three that we had were Caleb Lee
Hutchinson who was like this country
like you know vibe Maddie poppy who was
like this indie like known for her
soothing voice and strong artistic
ability and then Gabby Barrett who was
like a Miley Cyrus like wannabe so even
before the episode started I was just
thinking I'm like okay we went to every
city in the country went to the deep
south the west coast the East Coast we
saw everyone the most dynamic diverse
you know kind of different people and
our top three are literally like three
blond white kids like with no style or
flavor and I was like this is so lame
I'm like this is not America first of
all so it's pissed off to start I think
the most talented one was maybe Caleb or
Gabi and neither of them won anyway so
like no matter if anyone want I would
have been disappointed because like I
was just thinking of all the people we'd
come to see on American Idol journey
that girl whose wife was in the [ __ ]
army and she like came out and she was
killer like she was so much more dynamic
no other three of them put together Noah
Davis like I was just thinking I'm like
oh we went through so many people so
many like different characters eight of
box like so many interesting people and
we end up with three vanillas I was like
this is so boring and lame I got vanilla
chocolate and a strawberry and like to
the credit of an arc retinol they did
produce an amazing finale like they
stopped they pulled out all the stops
for the celebrity talent like Caleb
singing wagon wheel with Darius Rucker
was like everything I needed I [ __ ]
love that song and I loved Darius Rucker
and caleb is really good at what he does
being boring and it was great like it's
a boring saw it was great Katie Turner
like I think justice needs to be served
for
justice needs to be served for her I
tune in for ten minutes and I caught
Katy Turner singing with Katy Perry who
looked beautiful who looked beautiful
they both looked beautiful they were in
sync oh my god it was honestly like
we'll share it on our honor Instagram it
is the most amazing performance first of
all I love that song I love them.i
dition that they did Katy Turner
she made me like well the feel a little
weird because she's like kind of a weird
girl but she like really came into her
own on the show and like I think she I
think she was robbed I don't know like
that she should have won um but that she
the members of absolutely beautiful also
that rendition was was better than the
original song because they kind of broke
it down to its essentials and I
memorized the part they sing part of me
by Katy Perry that it's a little update
and like you know cheesy which I love
and then they brought bebe Rexha back
and she's saying with all the top three
meant to be when she originally sang
with Caleb a couple weeks ago so like
the production value of the show was
very high quality I loved his
celebrities and loved the judges like
everything was great Lionel Richie
performed Luke Bryan performed then he
performed with Gabby and it was like
fine it was very vanilla like it was all
good like the performances were we're
okay but like the talent was there I
don't know I'm just like a little
disappointed I expected a tiny bit more
and now I'm like so motivated to try out
and I know I say that but I think I'm
gonna also justice for smash because she
has been ride-or-die for American Idol
all season like definitely helping them
stay afloat yeah and she's so
disappointed that she had to message
Gabby Barrett on Instagram well now
there's a bunch of speculation about
Gabby Barrett yeah and because she like
has a semi-professional career before
the show which really isn't allowed if
you're a singer she likes saying with
cole swindell she knows with Brian he
went on tour with Coulson it's also
weird and there's like weird screenshots
um all over the interwebs but what they
gathered is that like Luke Bryan had
reached out to her over a year ago and
said like I want you to be on American
Idol you're not gonna win but you'll
make it pretty far and then I want to
sign you to my management company which
it looks like is she didn't she didn't
come far she didn't win and she's super
close with him and she probably will be
on his record label yeah super everyone
wins in the end also Maddie and Caleb
are dating and they're going to Hawaii
and it was beyond awkward like I was
dying screaming cringing like it was
obviously fake and it was set up but
like
I feel like she wasn't down to be set up
with him and he was like so down cuz
like she's the winner she doesn't need
him and he was like riding on her coach
a winner no but like she's not my
American I don't know me neither but
like it was still awkward and like
obviously that kid kicked Gabby out
first because they're like we have a
trip for two to Hawaii so what were they
gonna send Caleb and Gabby like no they
had to connect and and then Ryan
Seacrest was like you know you do get +1
it's like implying that they probably
should invite Gabby and Kade who was
another contestant
they were dating also and Caleb was like
yeah we'll bring our parents like he
literally come out it was so weird the
whole thing was bizarre very bizarre and
very unfair for the people who watched
all season not me but snitch I said okay
to Perry like I think she needs a break
so I've asked you this before and by now
I need you to have your answer I think I
know what it is but what if you were to
perform on a mare if you were to try out
for American Idol what would be your
song what would be your Edition I really
don't know like I'm so dynamic in my
voice but I would want to sing something
that's reflective of like the image I
want to be like a lot of the songs that
I sing there Broadway but I don't they
literally say to people like you're to
Broadway like this is a pop this is
America yeah so I would probably do like
Sunday morning member and five even
though it's like so lame and everyone
sings that yeah we're like the Kacey
Musgraves song I would have to figure
that I see Maria or Marian yeah I don't
know I really like it if you want to be
like famous you should be a country
artist because I feel like we'll have
the most fun that way yeah but like they
don't really like good thing that's
almost not like super famous except I
don't I feel like from these shows of
most people oh you only famous in your
we go country yes like Raylan I did a
SoulCycle yesterday that was musical
Monday theme so it's all musical songs
and it was so crazy Evan Hanson yes they
had a since sincerely me like dear Evan
Hanson oh I hate that song and then
waiting through a window and like every
other song was like unreal and then
every other song was like all that
Jetson doing which was annoying but the
songs that were unreal like I literally
was screaming at the top my legs
actually appreciated the brain which one
they did let it go oh nice defying
gravity notes on this song from rent did
the best one it's like a tiger in a cage
yeah what's it called
um take me baby oh yeah
so good and then waiting fair one no it
was just it was it was sometimes later
Thanks and I hadn't worked out in so
long and I felt like it was like a lot
of workouts and yeah okay last name was
the finale of everything American Idol
the voice versus charts I don't know who
I'm the voice but Adam Rippon beat Tom
Hardy but he was also an abridged
version of Dancing with the Stars
correct it was only like a four week
special I was an athlete special yeah um
duh Adam Rippon won
I can't believe talking Harding like was
even in second please no it's like Nancy
Kerrigan did it a few years ago I'm like
didn't make it half as far as Tonya yeah
it's really big universe just decided
that like it's time for Tonya Harding
and as a member of this universe
I just I'm here to say no it's not like
it's been like 40 years where the
universe had decided it's time for Nancy
Kerrigan and I have to be honest like
shake einde of like blue or chance
totally and you know Tanya's here let's
see what she does with her with her
opportunity like she's doing a lot show
unto the Oscars she went to the Oscars
she was a by Margot Robbie goes with the
stars with the stars and let's see
what's next for her yeah I'm excited if
she is like an agent
probably yeah maybe like I don't know
that's weird to think I know Nancy
Kerrigan's publicist
Nancy Kerrigan's publicist and then also
Miss USA was crowned as roscoe Miss
Nebraska Sarah Rose was crowned Miss USA
2018 I'm Kimberly we still have beauty
pageants like it's so archaic it's so
archaic but like I feel like it's always
like a good representation of like where
we're at as a country like depending on
the answers and then there's always like
the brouhaha around the answers and then
like does it show that you know
obviously our children are not being
educated with or NDI rocks exactly but
in the case of this woman our children
are actually doing okay okay um she had
two questions and the first one was or
she was asked to address the fact that
one in four children in the United
States live in a single-parent household
moores assist more specifically the
question was how has that affected our
generations views on marriage and family
that's an easy
it's an insightful question also it's
it's a hard question to [ __ ] but it's
not controversial yet right so she said
I'm so grateful to have grown up in a
home with two parents and I so I can't
personally relate to this however I do
work in children's hospitals as a
certified Child Life Specialist where
I'm a liaison between the child and the
families and the medical
and I've seen single mothers at the
bedside working remotely on their
computers to stay by their children and
support them and I think that it just
shows children no matter if it's a boy
or a girl that they can do that and then
her second question which was a little
more like you know timely was her final
scenario was imagining herself on the
way to a March what which and she had a
sign and a marker that's hard
what was she write on it that is really
hard yeah and you don't know like what
marks your grade so I say Sara says I
say speak your voice I don't know what
March were on our way to in this
hypothetical situation but no matter
where you're going whatever type of
March it is you're obviously on your way
to that March because you care about
that cause so go speak to people when
they have questions communicate with
them listen to their views also that is
one thing United States that we really
need to focus on is listening to each
other wow this girl was ready this girl
was ready she was she was in tune with
what was necessary and I'm glad she
wasn't I think also a lot of the pageant
is luck and hopefully you don't get that
controversial question yeah no oh my god
that is like those were dream questions
yeah if someone were to ask you're like
what are you sense don't abortion like
know that it's impossible you can't win
you can't win you just so I'm happy for
her I'm a [ __ ] woman I look at
speaking of abortion I look forward to
seeing what she does at the platform
yeah but like it's not even a real
platform anymore I feel like back in the
day it had more meaning and Olivia culpo
took it to the place that it could be
and like but that's as far as you can
take it as being a living a couple so
you could take it pretty damn far no no
but she was like born under a lucky star
and I know she had a lot of help yeah
but maybe this girl is born under the
same star and also can get help I'll see
what I can do how about it in the
meantime that must be nice I'll do
everything I can okay who can be
condemned it must be nice to just be
Miss USA like I think that's a great
it's a great job except like a temporary
job it has an expiration date yeah and
today 364 days she already lost one
that's like really sad to think that but
she can make the most of her three more
days and maybe parlay it into a career
and you can always become like a host or
something no like literally just get
those interim followers girl you have
364 days you need a thousand followers a
day minimum yeah you need to come out
let's see let's see where she's out now
anyways but I think it's like it said
when you're president like you have
Instagram then you also have the Miss
USA instrument the POTUS one she's got a
like cross-promote and like you gotta do
it in a way that's seamless and which it
requires a lot of skills so if you're
not skilled - this isn't for you so
speak up speak now
well this for that I would say wait she
said speak up now I say speak your voice
speak your voice
honestly that's like not that good speak
your voice no I or what like what's the
better version no but it's like how
would you think I'm gonna answer on the
spot like that so it's yes your voice so
luck is not an English thing so this is
what I would say raise your voice yeah
hear me roar raise your voice by Hilary
Duff yeah it's okay come exact suit what
if you went on Miss USA that was your
talent of course your questions your
voice it was all just like raise up flag
and then in the middle of the show I'd
be like Paul same one more mile to
Jericho the walls can also someone's
watch know the beautiful you guys what a
beautiful movie no it's such a good
movie and like her brother Paul's like a
really famous actor the one who died
also isn't kat dennings in it yes she's
the emo piano play yeah so like it's all
coming back to Josh Groban and she's
from Flagstaff I remember that Arizona
so people won't know what the pink thing
I was drinking was its water with
electrolytes because I do this thing
when I go on Atkins and on the weekend
say you like crap so on the beginning of
the week I have to go through induction
again which is like so painful so the
electrolytes help me stay afloat also
speaking of shameless self-promotion
I have a couple tickets left to my
Nashville show and I really think
everyone should come also speaking of
shameless self-promotion about ninety
nine point eight thousand segrand it's
like so crazy it's actually like it's an
exciting place too because I feel like
once I get to a hundred I'll be so
worried about it going back down it's
kind of like nice to like only have to
go up from here but there's obviously
millions of you watching right now so
it's like just 200 of you could follow
me and make my dreams come true today
today would be a nice day make that
happen
okay so my national show is on June 5th
gonna be lettuce [ __ ] I'm gonna have
some gas there's like 30 tickets left so
I think I'm run should buy one or 30
people and also June 28th to the 30th
I'm coming to Chicago so don't make any
plans I can't give all the details yet
but like if you have a planner like
Jackies pencil me yeah use a pencil
because what if it's like the 29th it's
a whole you do have a planner you know
how stressful that could be yeah do you
use pens or pencils I use pen but like
say I needed to keep June 28th to the
30th oh and I would either make a note
in the sidebar or I would make a symbol
on the 28th of 30th just a seat just so
I can like know because I'm not you're
not I'm not on vacation for it the 28th
to the 30th it's just one night only
what not only not only I'd be looking at
my trial for a Maronite off with that I
don't you work on my breathing because
like I can't sing one song without
literally like gasping for air yeah
Chesson guest on yes but you know it's a
good way to work on your breathing
lossing I was at Mill and singing or so
oh great she'll say yes like I could
have gone on tour last night except like
I wonder what I actually sounded like is
great I couldn't hear myself very good
okay this next story is just you know a
nice way to talk about more details that
I've been merged about the Royal Wedding
okay on which is that James Corden
reveals how he nearly interrupted the
royal wedding okay that's so misleading
so misleading basically like he has
allergies there were flowers he was
trying not to sneeze during does anyone
have any objections honestly I could see
it was so far back we wouldn't have even
know totally also like nice way to make
the world a wedding about you know
totally but he said like really nice
things about the wedding and I've just
been watching like all these videos and
I saw a video compilation that someone
put in the toasters of Megan Markel
talking about just like women and during
the phase where pre Harry where she was
like being an activist she is so
well-spoken and I even remember when I
watched a movie where she kisses however
that like she like there's something
about her that she really does have like
a Marco sparkle yes and I think what was
a shame about the wedding is that we
didn't hear her talk really so I didn't
get that but she there's something like
so like sparkly sparkly and like she
really pulls you in yeah no I've seen
that video Ashton Kutcher shared on his
Facebook page where it's like a
compilation
no it's just that one speech where she's
wearing a black off the shoulder
shirt and she's wearing a low bun well
this was right about the commercial this
was like a highlight reel of just some
of her greatest moment yeah and it was
it was lit okay and did you see that
Buckingham Palace like updated their
website uh-huh with her bio yeah really
suits is on the second page and focuses
on her humanitarian efforts and her work
as of him as being a proud feminist yes
but she's just like so yes she's really
progressing that place up if they really
are in James Corden had really nice
things to say about the wedding I kind
of want to read them cuz I mean it was
lovely quote I've known Prince Harry
about seven years now and it was
wonderful said Corden it was one of the
most beautiful ceremonies I've ever been
to it was gorgeous
it was a whole affair it was happy it
was joyous and it was uplifting courting
joke that he was much happier than he
appeared in photos and videos quote in
my defense what defense do you make
while listening to a cellist in a church
people were like why he's so grumpy what
do you want me to be doing like rocking
out Corden said with a laugh it was
British at its Britain at its finest it
was a picture-perfect day and I feel
like it definitely was Britain at its
finest yeah he said it was the most
wonderful and inclusive service I was
proud to be British on that day it was a
modern forward-thinking couple having
the exact ceremony that they wanted they
thought Britain in the world
they brought Britain and the world
together for a happy occasion and I was
so pleased to be there that's so nice I
would have been pleased to be there too
yeah I just couldn't get there done no
but have you heard anything else about
the wedding no have you heard anything
else about Thomas Marr Cole yeah he was
spotted getting a Frappuccino he was at
the same internet cafe that he had the
photos you don't know but it's like it
contradicts his story about how just
having heart surgery totally you can
have a Frappuccino and you just had
heart so you can't have a Frappuccino
even if you're in the picture of health
yeah they're just like so so bad for you
it was like a vanilla bean from
Starbucks worse like what vanilla beans
are like that was what we thought was
fattening right now like whoo vanilla
bean eighty calories spooky you know
some any calories that you just saw it
so like a Frappuccino is like a vanilla
bean on top of the vanilla right right
that's really not good for you Thomas
Marco I just like I want everyone to
leave him the hell alone
I just wanna know what the mom's up to I
like think about her all the time no and
do you think I think the American like
paparazzi are going to like respect her
and leave her alone oh well you know
like she back in the States yet I don't
have lean on
well what did she do think hang with her
daughter she's with Harry oh you know is
she not remarried I I guess not
do you think she'll move to like London
to be here she should yes yes she should
and then she'll be like so procedures no
respect I guess it'll depend what she
wants like if she wants the royal
treatment go to London cuz we don't I'm
sure let's listen to whatever Megan says
you don't even have a royal treatment
here yeah I mean look at us if they did
I mean we are sitting in Thrones
sanitarium yeah I also did you see that
Megan Markos friend who like had her
Pippa moment know which friend oh yes
but she didn't like I remember reading
weeks before the wedding that Megan
Marcos Fran I guess her name is Jessica
that she was gonna be the Pippa I think
she is the girl whose sons she's that
really really cool Canadian woman whose
sons were holding the train oh she's
like the COO was the coolest person
there okay but this is why the media is
so annoying weeks before the wedding
I read Jessica Mulroney is going to have
a Pippa moment at the wedding so they're
like setting this up then Jessica
Mulroney walks into the church so they
obviously take a picture of me behind I
didn't see this picture anywhere then I
get this story today Jessica Mulroney
planned her big Pippa moment no no you
guys obviously had to walk so you and
then you're pretending like she did this
she was sure to get there she's like you
mean you you expose yourself
I just can't and I just so stupid very
stupid we see right through you daily
now okay do you want to do your toasters
today or tomorrow notes or tomorrow cuz
we don't have anything to recap tomorrow
and I want to talk about Vanderpump
rules let's go for it
okay part three of the reunion was the
part that we needed because we wasn't
getting up and and like any can't
wrangle these kids in know and he
honestly like he was being so relaxed
like he didn't care yeah but also he was
like yelling at everyone he was like
kind of really weird
Sheena's thing she didn't watch the show
it was like so rude he was like when
when Kristin was like it's really
unprofessional yeah it is it's like when
you're in class you call that for not
doing the reading like yeah she was so
unprepared and by the way she does watch
it no but here's the thing
her story didn't make sense because she
said she fast forwarded through other
people's scenes because like she had to
watch it quickly but then she said she
wants her own relationship so you didn't
watch anyone
scenes and you didn't want your machines
the hell did you watch but chuck it was
literally like the lalala show last
night she's everything I'm like I
totally fell for her when she was she
literally couldn't talk about crying cuz
I feel like she's really overprotective
of her boyfriend and like I totally got
that without like and the second someone
says something mean about someone you
love like you blur I can't talk and like
it was James who she put all of her
trust in like I'm sure James like know
knows everything everything like where
the bodies are buried if there are
bodies and like to be betrayed by that
person who literally is such a dweeb
and she never betrayed him is that her
such a betrayal yeah no she was like
what she almost to a fault
like how much she really stood out for
James even when he was like a an an ass
and I really like felt for her and I and
she said something oh my god that really
like it struck me she was like I think I
know what you're and she was like last
year like we said such mean things about
people I'm like I really thought we
liked learned together I'm like I'm
we're trying to change and then like you
go and say these like horrible fat
shaming things about my boyfriend it's
like I thought we were like learning
together like such a mature thing to say
she was like she did say some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] about people she call people fat
when made from their nose is like yes
you can [ __ ] up and like learn and like
a year later be a different better
person totally also when she was like
praying that what he said didn't air
like she was still trying to protect him
yeah and then she was like just you know
what that air it's like our relationship
is so the same yeah and but like she was
still trying to like protect I can't of
course you know what it's just the first
second that I wasn't there but like I
had just I'm so excited for this coming
season for so many things first of all
like the respect for Lala diversity
R'lyeh to continue and grow and I feel
like she's really gonna be like a main
character wait when she got up I went to
the bathroom and like everyone followed
her which was weird Lisa ban or public
shoving people out of the bathroom and
then wanting to be in the middle of her
and Jains she grabbed James she grabbed
Lala they were gonna talk she's like no
go sit down she like was being such a
stage mom getting them to the stage like
she was really pissed being Bobby
Fischer yes she was really playing chess
with them literally wear her pawns
speaking of plank chess with Bobby
Fischer did you get that email last
night no I did RSVP for us what is it
tomorrow night we're going to the
premiere of American woman with tell
Richard in the city yeah American woman
is Kelly Clarkson gonna be there she's
Kelly Clarkson sings a theme song
paramount network is like cool I'm gonna
wear right around them live okay I have
to find something I'm oh that's so
exciting I know um
so exciting yeah wait I want to go back
to a venom from pearls and I wanna go
back to LA I love her dress she looks so
skinny also okay so one thing that I
really liked is when we kind of get a
sense of like one when Jax was like why
would I stay here like all I'm a
bartender at Sur when they talk about
the elephant in the room which is that
they are waiters yes and when Tom
Sanibel was complaining that Stassi
should have come back as a waitress yeah
and then like Stassi was trying to you
know make it seem like a real thing as
opposed to like when they were like they
wanted someone for this position like
not like production needed me to work in
the restaurant yeah I very much
appreciated that and then Tom saying
about something said something that I
thought was so interesting he said he
was like even Lala is still a hostess
like as in like she's above us and she's
still a hostess I was like that I felt
like that spoke but like the intricacies
of the restaurant like have real
bearings on like who we see on the show
and it means no [ __ ] sense I think
the restaurant if we never went to sur
again like in the show I would be
pleased yeah but then it's like the see
you next Tuesday stuff is really good
and like James Kennedy doesn't work at
Sur and she's like not a cast member no
is not in anything she was barely on the
reunion
yeah and that but that's like Lisa like
punishing her yeah so it's like a second
dick Diana but meanwhile that's like the
greatest episode of TV ever so we should
really be thanking Kristen Dodi right
but like it's crazy how she like she
Lisa Vanderpump has final say because
Kristen is not bad like she should be on
the show she's a great character but
like and if you were gonna kick her off
there was a season where she was a
legitimate psychopath and when she was
making her t-shirts and that was the
season to like cut ties not now when
people like her and she's in a good
morning yeah it's just it's also
interesting how it comes back to the
restaurant and like it pisses me off
because that's like at least a minor
pump is indispensable yeah and because
of the rest but I'm glad that like at
least Lisa has respect for Stassi
because like we got her back in the f
full time and staffing he's being funny
when she went well I'm James were
fighting and she was literally sitting
in between right just like this seating
was so marred really weird because they
put people who were argue arguing with
each other on the same side so you like
look at each other to argue with you
awkward and honestly everyone's pretty
much under terms except lishchyna yeah
and it's gonna be they're gonna start
filming soon and it's gonna be
interesting like I feel like this could
be like near the end for scheana I don't
think so in the beginning she cared so
much about being friends with everyone
she was like almost to a fault that like
Ariana was like her good friend and like
all she wanted was to be friends with
the witches a WeHo and like she finally
got it and then she like realized it
wasn't all this cracked up to me they
were still mean to her and like I don't
I feel like she's at the point where
like she doesn't care anymore and I feel
like she and like by the way the only
reason that you wouldn't be on the show
anymore is if this is what damodaran was
here I was like what is the the
reasoning behind kicking someone off the
show whether it's like housewives or
Vanderpump rules
they're like honestly it only has to do
with like if they're really friends with
the people like if no one's friends of
them and they're not had them hanging
out is it natural then that's the only
reason someone we got a job so if no
one's friends machine except for
Brittany and like Brittany's someone's
plus-one like you know Ariana's turns
machine oh yeah and like I feel like
with the upon world she still works out
the restaurant there is an excuse for
them to all be together and I think that
scheana will always care in general like
always care what people think about her
always want to be accepted and loved by
people right now she's like focusing on
herself and her Vegas show and like that
she's caring about that yeah but once
she gets back to LA to film like she's
gonna care once more and like she's
gonna have to get her hands dirty yeah
and I know and it'll be good okay but
then I was thinking like when is man
like everything all good things must
come to an end and they're all like
reaching for tea when is Vanderpump
rules gonna end not that I want it to
but like well one of two ways it could
go like until it's done and live its
life or they keep bringing in new people
like James and all are only 27 like that
they're they have ten years on them yeah
so like and now we have Billy Lee right
left maybe they just Jeremy like they
keep bringing in new younger characters
maybe Jeremy's not gonna do it for me
but not at all but I could use in like a
lot
2.0 or that guy Adam but then it's like
we spend some of the season Adam Adam
the one spends so much of the season
like working out the kinks of them being
brought in that like we never get to the
meat of the fights with the original
characters right you know like it's like
once you know my problem with the show
is that like now that they're all like
true celebrities and have like things to
lose they're a lot more careful so like
Kristen's not crazy anymore stassi's not
great
anymore Katie's not crazy anymore like
no one's crazy but then it's like I
don't need to see people being crazy and
like doing things that are like
unbelievable like Jax having sex with
face I do know I like when they go on
trips and it's like the the arguments
like the penny [ __ ] it's like you know
sassy freaking out at her birthday party
like that sort of like totally
disagreement there's a real friendship
stuff that like like having real fights
like that like I thought the whole
Jack's cheating storyline was so
annoying the tomtom storyline was so
annoying I just want to see these girls
go out have drinks someone says
something to bother someone they fight
about it they get over it moving on no I
liked like when they were beating each
other up taking off the tricky sweaters
in Vegas right did that like we're never
going to say the board never gonna get
in that again it's not so soon but a lot
of the drama that was from this season
like uneven like James and Kristen
hooking up to be hanging out to be hook
up don't need they didn't even clarify
that in the episode it really pissed me
off yeah like I thought finally went
money we were still saying they said
okay they were still saying I said he
finally got them all together in the
reunion room and they had the tapes
they'd be able to just clear it up
really quickly it was all in
misunderstanding they said hang out not
hook up but [ __ ] Tom Sandoval's still
saying they said hooked up that really
pissed me off I was like I just wanted
some clarification justice needs to be
served justice needs to be served also
then doing the shot of pasta that pasta
looked unbelievable
she told scheana it was totally been
about go first vodka like shots which is
a machine alike a Liberty struggling to
get one noodle in her lips was like
really scary yeah also they should serve
that at Sur now like yeah as an
appetizer I'm sure they have something
where it's like it's not about the pasta
they should yeah they should react bring
Raquel because what is she gonna say it
would have been interesting for her to
be there when they're talking about how
James is in love with Allah but they
talked like she was there in the season
and it wasn't interesting for her no
she's wildly uninteresting you know it's
so crazy but I'm happy if they're happy
also I watched southern charm on st. you
really need to start watching just like
dynasty oh oh I started trying to see
it's so good told you I'm just like
southern Trump does not I've watched it
and I've given it a chance it's so good
no not for me oh my god it's so good I'm
obsessed with hidden justice for Naomi
because I watched watched her die beside
last night Kathryn and Craig were on
which was interesting because their show
wasn't home last night and Kathryn looks
I mean like she's in such a good place
and so happy for her and her and Craig
are good friends and I love them
but apparently like Naomi's rep this
season is that she's like so crazy and
mean but like that's something five I'm
getting like no she's just calling
people out from here now she's just a
full time cast member so we're hearing
from her whereas before I'd like we only
heard from her when like she was in the
scene right so I can't
and the shent you guys it's like an
Erica Jane situation where it's like no
one's on my side and I don't understand
why sometimes when like I have a very
particular stance on like a housewife
issue and I find people that don't
disagree with me like it really makes me
like think differently of other people
but then it's like when the whole
country doesn't agree with you and make
sure like it starts making me question
myself and I were like then affirm with
myself and I'm good yeah that question
no but it really like you learn a lot
about other people based on like which
housewife they side with I totally agree
you guys thank you so much for being
here make sure you follow the morning
toast on Facebook Instagram and YouTube
we go live 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we go
live on Facebook so make sure you like
us and we go live on YouTube so make
sure you're subscribed and you give this
video a thumbs up
then we're available in the podcast app
the morning toast leave us a review 5
stars about how gorgeous we are buy
tickets to my Nashville show they're at
the link in my bio on my Instagram girl
with no job please leave the site right
now and go follow me at Jackie O
problems you guys were gonna do it today
and once I get 200k I'm gonna post
something like really spectacular to a
nudie really I was either gonna post my
engagement video or like meaneth
balloons really but something sexy like
cover your boobs and your ass but like
exactly really yeah that's the sort of
thing you do to get to 100k no they
deserve it okay I'll get to 150 guys um
we love you bye bye